dass die produktionen pizzen videos von
quelle
ein weiterer tag ist vergangen meine
damen und herren youtube deutschland
wurde noch nicht durch beton endgültig
in die luft gesprengt
alle youtuber die darüber video kümmert
haben tieren so langsam zu ihrem
normalen content wird und genauso machen
wie das der bauch heute deswegen darf
ich euch herzlich meine lunge dann doch
wieder nicht als bruder übergang von
webber zu meinem normalen content hab
ich mir gedacht ich verbinde das ganze
mit clever bord und stellen dem clever
board einfach mal ein paar fragen über
die beton und ob er vielleicht ein paar
geheime hintergrund informationen dazu
besitzt ich meine wir alle sitzen ein
paar tagen ein neues video aufgetaucht
was angeblich die original
unbearbeiteten tonaufnahmen von baby
zeigen soll jemand ganz kurzer
ausschnitt aber leute nicht weiter
verbreiten
ich habe mir schon wieder anbieten mit
dem clever bot geschrieben zum beispiel
was für eine kalte weil er da vor
irgendwas mit einer kerb geschrieben hat
die alten star geld haben dann irgendwie
ich dann geschrieben ich bin kein star
denn er habe ich auch nicht gesagt
natürlich was kann für das heilbad nicht
was kannst du ich kann wie wie song
anhören steigendem also ganz leicht in
die unterhaltung mit einem darauf
antworten der körperlich nicht sehr
clever bord kann sich den sorgen also
nicht mal anhören die fangen auch wieder
mal ganz simpel an kennt die beauty
pelle sieber clever wort nein wer ist
das reine der deutsche tuner
dann sagt die lösung
wer kennt es nicht
ich beschreibe eine person ist wie soll
die lösung sagen
doch klar dass die lösung eine damen und
herren du bist weg jahre älter
mal angenommen ich wäre dann wäre der
carebot 11
gerade mit einem minderjährigen zurück
zum thema baby eintracht mal schauen was
da für ein feld doch so hat gefragt ob
ich heute vor tieren habe ich gefragt
wie war clever bord doch das hat nein
habe ich nicht lieber clever bord ja du
bist die neue box
vorstellen meine damen und herren hey
ich bin die neue bot wie findest du die
beauty fälle bieber clever bord nicht
gut
auch nicht ich auch nicht nun soll
und darauf antwortete care o bot dann
haben wir etwas gemeinsam ja genau
beantwortet wahrscheinlich hast du schon
wo
was zum facebook warum fragte mich wo
hast du ihren neuen form gehört ich
glaube der hat wohl schon so fragt nein
bin nichtraucher peschel
er bewertet das lied von bibi als
zigarette und sagt jetzt nicht darauf ab
ich für mich selbst beschützen
doch einfach mal ab werk vom komponisten
wenn du grad frostig
lava der wahl scheiße war es ist ja der
form bin ich okay erklärt der clever
bord ist also sieht also ein lied clever
bot wird nein eine deutsche leicht ist
der clever bot gebieten buch bieber
clever wort warum sollte mein gott er
war ich der frage aus weil du es gerade
angedeutet hat lieber clever bord ist
mutter ganz auf die spur gehen erzähl
mir was du bist
das muss ich dir denen wir clever bot
nein ich bin nicht böse
o
der clever wort für die börse findet die
wirklich
der fährt halt mal interessant zu wissen
ja das finde ich
okay wir sind mittlerweile so weit dass
der klemme bord wirklich als böse
abstempelt soll ich dir etwas vorsingen
klarer worte gerne
was kann ich denn da singen
[Musik]
ja es ist sonnig aber war dass in meinem
gewinne zu tun hast die geheime
hintergrundinformationen zum neuen form
von ibi lieber klar aber das ist eine
frage die interessiert deutschland nein
ich bin ein mädchen das beantwortet
meine frage nicht ich möchte wissen was
wir damit klar passiert ist er starb
beim anhören
neuen baby bekommt leitet das beibringen
zu müssen erklären das ist kein
richtiger grund dafür doch das lied ist
kacke
nein ich weiß es wohl besser nein tust
du lieber kam aber doch ich bin
unsichtbar
warum eine lampe
gefallen
meine damen und herren um zwischendurch
ein bisschen werbung zu machen wie schon
oben wäre video eingeblendet denn ich
zeige euch hier die leute die plötzlich
mit lucio fordert drauf und auch luca
toni in den ring bietet am ersten tor
zusammen mit vier anderen produkt in
einem ersten sechs neuen luca shop jeden
zudem kommt er nicht was uns gibt es
zwar schon gezeigt aber das müsste jetzt
glaube ich auch wieder gelöscht sein
aber meine damen und herren erste 6.15
uhr luca - shop.de abo nehme ich doch
mal wenn ihr
schnauze luca in jedem video letzter
zeit hänge ich einfach nur zwischendurch
nach 23 minuten am handy und back to
topic
[Musik]
und der erste präsident
wir stoßen hier langsam wirklich in der
wehrkraft hintergrundinformationen rein
ich habe vor ein paar tagen dieses video
weitergeleitet bekommen von einer sehr
bekannten fälle wo original aufnahmen
von bibi zu verzeichnen sind
apple hat dazu schon wieder auf seinem
kanal gemacht es kamen andere
informationen raus über die
produktionskosten des videos ich weiß
gar nicht ob das spruchreif aber wir
fragen einfach mal den clever bord was
er zu dem produktions vor zu sagen wie
teuer war das in videos video von baby
sehr teuer
ja
also ich kann das nicht ganz einschätzen
ob das viel geld ist für musik video
dann nicht wenn hier keine falschen
informationen veröffentlichen
publizieren oder irgendwelche leute
damit im freudvoller stellen oder
geschweige denn mich selber irgendwie
ins kreuzfeuer zu stellen allerdings
wurde mir von zwei quellen zugetragen
sehr seriöse tatsächlich möchten aber
beide anonym bleiben da die produktion
ist die videos von hausgemachter von
50.000 euro gekostet haben soll ich weiß
nicht ob das mittel ist also es gibt
locker musikvideos von michael jackson
bieber oder so die disney millionen hoch
gehen das ist aber dann auch wirklich
musik also wie gesagt 50.000 euro ist in
meinen augen eine menge geld
ich denke für jeden normalen menschen
eine menge geld allerdings für wirklich
musikvideos glaube ich eher nicht aber
wenn man damit vergleichbar das
musikvideo überhaupt ist also man hat
eine location das ist ein haus mit
luftballons drinnen dann ist es sehr
teuer
der komponist des liedes heißt im sommer
überhaupt nichts gegen sommer oder
überhaupt nichts gegen die skylab
verstehen viele jahre alt glaubst du
jetzt privaten bewegungsprojekt braucht
sein aber die musik na ja also ich
glaube fast zwei millionen entsprechen
eigentlich bericht zum thema
zurückzukommen
im sommer ist der komponist von diesem
sommer reichen schon mal ein paar andere
lieder aus gebratene lecker lecker
mit ganzen und mein traum ich weiß dass
apple vor ein paar tagen dann hier
drüber gemacht hat soll genau die
gleichen sachen gesagt hat die hatte ich
nämlich an ihn weitergeleitet und ich
hatte die wieder über den haufen fällen
bekommen also ich überhaupt nicht
irgendwie um schauspielen check gern ein
video auf youtube fans man aber leute
willkommen zurück zum erklärt und frage
ihn einfach mal ob er zumindest im
sommer kennt da wo ich mich von den
übergang schaffen und fragten im sommer
lieber klavier ist eine gute freundin
warum zu fisch kommt er auf siri to be
viewed pellet lieber clever bord oder du
bist mein alter ich tue was dieser dann
ding für mich lieber clever bot ja was
soll ich fuhren meister
hä
beim meister nicht mal groß schreiben
kann und wenn ihr mir ein lied lieber
clever borletti
titel
sbs und let it be haben genau gleiche
buchstaben meine damen und herren
lieber körper gut tut mir leid
ich dachte gerade das leid das einzige
wort das was du falsch geschrieben wurde
aber gehen wir mal den satz kritische
durch ruß mir leid ich weiß nicht was du
isst ich jene nur dumm keine satzzeichen
3 rechtschreibfehler
ja anscheinend ist der kleber bot
wirklich wie youtube fälle was ist das
am meisten gibt video der welt wieder
clever porter schauen ob es überhaupt
noch wirklich wert ist eine stadt in
hessen
geburtstags von bb das tier vom video
meine damen und herren noch mal hier zum
abschluss ist ab 2 stunden häufig gesagt
ich will kein komplettes video darüber
machen wie ich die leidige oder ein
komplettes video nur dieser sache wird
wenn ich will das halt ganz gerne mit
anderen sachen publicity beispielsweise
hier mit dem clever bot ich hoffe ihr
versteht das sich nie was ging sekunden
hinter dem content habe damals sagte
miguel pablo als damit konnte nicht
einfach dankbar und das verstehen die
leute einfach nicht nur weil ich
beispielsweise sagen dein content
einfach komplett oder wie die psyche
pellet seine musik ist komplett
beschlossen habe ich nicht gegen die
person und dahinter weil ich diese
person einfach persönlich kenne und da
möchte ich nicht über die urteilen job
ihr versteht was ich damit meine
unterschied ist einfach der zeit zu der
erste hype in deutschland der übelste
trend geht einfach so komplett jeder
weiß was das ist einfach und da wir
natürlich alle leute wissen dass
mitglieder der plattform youtube com
berichten wir natürlich darüber und
passt unseren content darauf an
deswegen würde ich dann meine damen und
herren wenn euch das video heute
gefallen haben sollte das gerne waren
like da auch wenn ihr mehr clever
vorgehen wollte jetzt bin ich nun hier
eine eingeblendete darauf lege ich
meinen kanal abonnieren und sehe immer
das irgendwie 30 40 prozent seiner
zuschauer überhaupt nicht abonnenten
sind also klickt er verdammt noch mal
drauf da und mensch auch eingeblendet am
ersten wechsel ein sport wie gesagt
unter anderem diese zeit und noch vier
andere produkte hier unten
ein weiteres video verlinkt
gay